hi I'm mark and we've been married for
over 40 years he didn't let me say
anything you're supposed to say I am
mark and then I say hi I'm Diana okay
start over hi I'm Mark Evans and we we
have a grandson and yesterday we at
Father's Day we were told we have
another grandchild on the way I can't
believe you said that
read it out loud and then I'm gonna do
this yes again I'm gonna talk about it
yeah about it okay okay never have I
ever gotten so drunk that I needed my
parents to pick up
I would have been shot if I did that I
was I drank a little bit heavier as a
teenager I than as a teenager with a
spike in my 20s but I never got it I
never lost complete control and I did it
really yeah I never drink until I was an
adult stuff never have I ever lied to
get out of spending time with my kids
aiya but I love spending time with our
kids like you that's part of our life
they come first and eventually conversa
no never
they come first never have I ever looked
at porn I'm curious I have I guess yes
and you want to talk about it beer
movies together uh yes no shortage you
said be honest until the not even go to
jail if we well I know no no never have
I ever got a speeding ticket
I was dating a girl and I was driving
home on the 405 I was pulled over
officer please
I've taken my my date home because her
parents would be so mad at should be in
a lot of trouble well he wrote the
ticket smiled said she's in trouble
never have I ever thought my grandkids
were better than my kids oh well we have
two other greatest sons who love them
dearly and couldn't love it more and
they were they're precious and they're
turned out to be phenomenal but re
grandson is the sweetest most loving fun
child you could ever be around so I'm
not putting our kids down I love you no
no put down but this little grandkid is
so special if I cry it's so sweet so
special and you know when you're raising
your children it's hard work and you're
not sure am i doing the right thing am I
not doing the right thing now they were
they were great kids it's a hard work
never have I ever not into a movie we
did I don't want to I know I didn't that
rule followers I even tell the guy that
I said I don't like doing this but I did
it because they wouldn't even stand
outside waiting for but I think nobody
would not do it oh never have I ever
skinny-dipped
I have definitely done before I met you
it's a hippie dippie days you know
things were different then both parts to
a marriage me but they should not both
be
do that only ones allowed me to ban and
so we allowed her to but even before I
met her okay
sure show us how many fingers how many
times ha never have I ever tried hard
you like though have to Disneyland and
grant night I did oh I know most of the
stuff yeah I just don't want to remember
that I said that
have I ever snuck out of the house I was
raised you know I was raised decent and
I didn't have anything that needed I
didn't need to escape
that's have a thing so no I have my
freedom and you know my parents were
pretty good I probably scared them a lot
of times not coming home because I was
at a boyfriend's house that kind of
thing but they knew I was with him I
never stuck out was furiously got to go
skin an ugly baby snuck out when I was
getting you know
never lying up liking someone my child
data I wouldn't tell them to their face
that I didn't like the person they were
with it kind of waited to see what would
happen
and then after like yeah they dated
decent girls nice girls and so far so
isn't it there's never anything
everything but this is wrong for you
never have I ever gotten arrested oh no
pretty good grandparents ever smoked pot
you never had have you did too with me I
haven't since no since this weekend in
Paris
and I never wanted my kids to know if
you ask our kids if they ever had I
think all of us have because we were I
mean you know it you know they're the
Jenna this is the generation so yeah
yeah yeah yeah never have I ever had a
favorite child or grandchild well I have
a favorite grandchild right now
he's the only one and he's
best we really are blessing it's it's I
know it's not not everybody is as
blessed but you think our lucky stars
that it's good stuff
never have I ever judged my child's
parenting skills I'd say not there's a
dog barking and you said let her know
that that is her know that you know he
said that's just a dog barking don't
worry about that and Ryan said I
wouldn't have brought attention to it
that's how we're raising our son yeah
it's like this is my child it's my child
and that hurt me he took it really
personally I took it personally mm-hmm
you know and he didn't mean any harm but
that was that's the only time that I had
a little incident you're protective he
was a protective dad
yes I love about him too never have I
ever forgotten a mixed or mixed up my
grand children's names yes you have we
both have tell them who you called her
Todd her grandson's name is Ezra and
there's been so many times where I would
call him Fievel that's our old dog why
are you calling that by I call him by
his dad's name Ryan
so I've done it all why yes is yes for
me never have I ever
I didn't I've never played it but um it
was really fun I think I said more than
I should have probably embarrassed later
by the police after everybody associate
would BuzzFeed treated us like stars he
gave us a chance to open up the wish
which is we're not holding anything back
all right our kids today should realize
it their parents and grandparents kind
of went through the same thing that
they're going through it's not that
different you know we were in the
trenches - we've been in this situation
your children today I think are more
health conscious and they're the
millennia
want to be minimalist I'll say one thing
being a grandparent is the best thing in
the world
I've watched everybody around me have
grandchildren and I always wanted to be
a grandparent and it finally happened
when they told us that remember I was I
just couldn't believe it I was so
emotional
[Music]